- I like to scream, "Puerto
Rico!" and that's about it.
(techno music)
- I'm expecting beans and rice.
- Since it's a U.S. territory,
I think it might be very American.
- I'm anticipating a lot of spice.
- Oh, I never thought about it.
Is it gonna be spicy?
It's gonna be crazy.
- Looks like a cracker of some kind with--
- with jelly on it
- frozen jelly.
- This is guava and this is a cracker.
- So the first thing
tastes bland to me but
it tastes so good with the fruity thing.
- It's got like this sweet salty combo.
- (mumbles) This is really good.
- This is what I would
eat when I was a kid
and my mom just wanted me to shut up.
She would give me stuff like this.
- Mmm!
- Yes, yes, okay.
- Oh man! This is like fried potato
with meat inside of it!
- Wow!
- Wow.
- Can we get this for lunch?
- Yeah, this is fantastic.
- The potato's kinda thicker.
- It'a a lot of potato for me.
- I recommend that.
- I would eat this.
- This looks like raisins,
which makes me very nervous.
- No, they're little black
beans with yellow rice.
- Mmm, it's good!
It's not as spicy as
I thought it would be.
- It's almost like you're questioning
if there is even a hint of spice.
- It's a little oily for my taste.
- I don't mind it.
- I would put some salt on this.
- (both) Mofongo!
- What did you just call me?
- That sounds like an
elephant in a Disney movie.
- I really like the pork.
The plantain is really dry.
- The pork is very subtle, it's not like
overpoweringly like what we're used to.
- This could use some salt.
- This is so good I'm gonna
name my first child Mofongo.
- (both) Mofongo!
- It smells like a Krispy Kreme doughnut.
- It kinda does smell like a churro.
I'm gonna drink the whole thing.
- Whoo! That was great!
- I would definitely
think there's rum in here,
cause it's a creamy drink.
- It's really bland.
- Yeah, the coconut taste, it's just,
too much, too much coconut.
- Like, just enough cinnamon, too.
- So this is only served during Christmas?
- This is actually good.
We need to replace eggnog with this.
- I would go to Puerto Rico just for this.
- You've impressed me, Puerto Rico,
you have impressed me.
- I have been impressed by the mofongo.
- I loved it. It was great.
- (both) Puerto Rico!
Puerto Rico! Puerto Rico!